and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bum
tonight's review
Oh I've ever seen in my life there's
this guy called Hancock who is a
superhero who also happens to be a pump
it's about freakin time
we need more bombs superheroes it was
like watching Superman but starring me
and his hobbies were drinking passing
out and eating very small children I do
all of those things except hitting small
children I only pick on the big one and
there's this public relations guy who
wants to help him but don't do it any
better work on me once he had me doing
things and saying things that totally
change the way I was care it looks
something like this
hi Chester Alfred B can I interest you
in a candle isn't that horrible so
having that besides he is going to go to
prison because he has been a bad
superhero it's like when the green
lanten raped Macaulay Culkin or did I
just feel better either way would be
pretty frightening and so had Nazis in
prison but he shoves one guy's head up
another guy's ass I'm totally serious he
shoves a guy's head up another guy's ass
more superheroes meet other people's
heads in the new Dark Knight movie The
Joker will be like I'm gonna kill
everybody and Batman is like you're
going inside an ass the end
so after Hancock gets out of prison the
people miss him and he turns into the
new superhero Hancock Hancock becomes
Hancock should he have a different name
like drunk man or schnockered boy or
dude I swear I thought she was over 18
person so Hank I find out when he's
around other people like him he loses
his powers kind of like what
around other bones I lose more change
this is my Twitter go find your own fire
hydrant manager do we have to fight the
bad guys while sometimes losing his
powers - he's like yeah go ahead
it's Captain Hook he must just hate
people who have the ability to fly why
would you add people who can fly that's
so cool if I could fly I would fly over
the city and shoot them all yeah like I
don't know